regardez ce nouvel Audi q8i Tron et bien
vous n'avez pas de rétroviseur à
l'extérieur c'est une petite caméra qui
est planqué juste là vous allez
retrouver un écran juste ici pour voir
ce qui se passe à l'extérieur il y a un
côté marrant mais un peu perturbant
parce que je suis pas habitué moi ça
fait plus de 20 ans que je conduis et
j'ai l'habitude de déporter mon regard
sur le rétroviseur et en fait là je dois
le reporter directement sur l'intérieur
du véhicule alors vous me direz pourquoi
est-ce qu'on vient supprimer rétroviseur
et qu'on met une caméra c'est surtout
pour venir gagner en terme d'autonomie
Audi nous explique qu'on va venir gagner
7 km d'autonomie en venant supprimer de
la résistance au vent d'un écran tactile
comme vous êtes sur une caméra bah vous
pouvez venir vous déplacer dessus voir
on va en bas sur le côté comme vous
voulez bref et après si vous voulez le
remettre en position comme il était vous
appuyez sur i7 et autant là j'ai rétro
de mon côté de mon côté conducteur
j'appuie là hop et je passe sur le rétro
passager ça vient bouger sur l'écran
côté passager qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez est-ce que ça vous plaît ce
système d'avoir une caméra ici alors
vous voyez c'est beaucoup plus fin il y
a moins d'empattements il y a moins de
prise au vent mais c'est très perturbant
de se retrouver et bien sans rétroviseur
extérieur sans venir jeter déporter
votre regard sur le côté je suis pas
habitué donc je sais pas si vous ça
pourrait vous intéresser est-ce que ça
pourrait vous tenter marquer moi ça bien
évidemment en bas dans les commentaires